spoiler alert Game of Thrones isn't a
series known for its happy endings and
fans certainly aren't getting many in
the show's final season several major
characters met their end in the fifth
episode of season eight and now the
actor who played Varys has revealed that
he wasn't thrilled with how his story
ended speaking with Entertainment Weekly
Conleth Hill opened up about the
experience of seeing his character
burned to death by the Mad Queen
Daenerys saying he took it very
personally I took it as a person not as
an actor or an artist I understood the
reactions of previous actors who had
been in the same position a lot more
than I did at the time you can't help
feeling that you failed in some way that
you haven't lived up to some expectation
that you didn't know about the only
thing that consoles you is people who
worked a lot harder than you are in the
same boat so that helps I don't think
anybody who hasn't been through it can
identify with it they think what's all
the fuss about you're all finishing
anyway but you take it personally you
can't help it
there was some bright side for Hill
though as he felt Varys died a noble
death after the master of whispers
revealed to the world the true parentage
of Jon Snow in an attempt to make sure
Westeros had a better ruler than the
vengeful and sadistic Daenerys he was
absolutely true to his word the whole
way through all he wanted was the right
person on the throne and a fair person
on the throne he said it so many times
in the scripts if he dislikes one MONUC
he conspires to crown the next one what
kind of servant is that the kind of the
realm needs incompetent should not be
rewarded with blind loyalty Hill
continued Varys didn't have the
distraction of love or desire or any of
those things and the people he needed to
see clearly were both in love so that
makes perfect sense and now with
hindsight I'm okay but I really was
inconsolable still the death stinks
especially considering how little Varys
has been given to do over the past two
seasons if you are frustrated by that
well you're not alone as he'll revealed
he wasn't too happy with his characters
arc either
I was very bummed to not have a final
scene with Littlefinger I was bummed not
to have any reaction to him dying if he
was my nemesis that's been my feeling
the last couple seasons that my
character became more peripheral that
they concentrated on others more that's
fine it's the nature of a multi
character show
is kind of frustrating as a whole it's
been overwhelmingly positive and
brilliant but I suppose the last couple
seasons weren't my favorite it just felt
like after season six I kind of dropped
off the edge I can't complain because
it's six great seasons and I had some
great scenes these last two seasons but
that's when it changed for me a little
hill also said that he felt like Varys
was acting out of character in those two
seasons as the master spy suddenly
seemed to have no idea what was going on
and exerted no influence over events
last season and this season there were
great scenes and then I'd come in and
kind of give a weather report at the end
of them film at 11:00 so I thought he
was losing his knowledge if he was such
an intelligent man and he had such
resources how come he didn't know about
things that was frustrating for a couple
seasons overall though he'll stressed
that his experience on Game of Thrones
has been brilliant and he doesn't think
fans will be disappointed with the
series finale I don't think they'll feel
cheated the fan favorites are all there
well all except one anyway check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]